there's a traditional way of coming up
in comedy like people go work as a
stand-up
right or they go to saturday night live
and they get an audition or something
like you came up in comedy with
cartooning right yeah i mean what i
wanted to do
was go into sketch comedy i mean but
then you know how do you do that yeah
how do you turn that into a living yeah
and and you'd watch
tv and i would always there'd be you
know johnny carson or something there'd
be somebody from second city tv and
they'd say how'd you start and i'd be
waiting for the moment well okay
how do i do this and it'd just be well
so and so universal called because they
were interested and
you're like whoa how do no one from
universal is calling me how do you know
well your story is great for some kid
who's listening to this show who wants
to get into comedy
you had a shitty little camera what was
the camera yeah the bollocks 16
millimeter
for 200 bucks you went out and bought it
and you said i'm going to make a film
yeah it was called office space which
later i did the movie that was the first
one i finished and it was like yeah two
minutes long and it was the character
milton
and the stapler and the boss coming in
and when you made the film you even said
you had it like just kind of try to like
sync your voices because like
60 millimeter film you had to go in
somewhere and record the voices right
yeah well i had one of those cassette
yeah with that would run the a and b
side together so you'd get four tracks
so you make this little film and and
what do you do do you send it to someone
i literally called information called
4-1-1
and i felt really stupid but i i'd
called you know new york information
there's no internet back then and
just uh say uh yeah mtv please and
at comedy central i just and i would get
the run around and then i would just get
a name
and an address and send i sent out vhs
tapes literally like a cold call like oh
totally yeah
you didn't know these people nobody
didn't even know anybody's name you just
uh who's the guy who's in charge of mtv
yeah well
i would say like they had that show
liquid television so i caught and of
course everyone's just
these people who answer the phone are
just love being an [ __ ] to you
like you're just some weirdo calling who
noticed it
the show kids in the hall called
actually wow cause
when i sent them that i'd done the
fourth short i'd made which was the
beavis and butthead short
it's kind of weird too with beavis and
butthead because i remember the first
time i saw it i was like whoa this is
really peculiar
already it was going on mtv and i
couldn't [ __ ] wrap my head around it
i kind of wanted it to be
i wanted it to look like maybe it was
made by a deranged person
yeah like maybe people would wonder but
it's so brilliant because it was so
simple you know
and you've said even like charlie brown
inspired you because it was such simple
drawings
yeah i love the way like just simple
animation like the way pig pen had all
those just
lines of dirt animating it was like it
was just like little pen lines
yeah it was nothing yeah you draw right
yeah that that i'm not really naturally
good at have to force myself
you drew the beavers and butt head color
yeah yeah i animated every of the shorts
yeah
animated the whole thing when i got it
looking the way i wanted it to yeah it
was model sheets that i drew all the
did you ever consider in the beginning
like having somebody else draw it
because
like as you said oh yeah well i mean
well when it became a show there were
other people drawing it and i realized
pretty quickly though that um
when someone would just do this they
kind of would morph it into just very
saturday morning looking stuff and it
wasn't funny anymore and
it needed that it needed to look shitty
yeah it needed to look shitty in a
very specific way and i was always open
to you know whatever works whatever
makes it funny did you draw king of the
hill
i drew the original uh yeah model sheets
the very first drawings of
them from most of the angles it's
amazing that you had the confidence to
draw also because you're not trained as
an artist no i'm i'm horrible
i know you know having come from having
been in in the music world and and kind
of seeing like
okay there's people who are technically
amazing like i don't know john
mclaughlin but i would actually
personally
rather listen to kurt cobain play guitar
somebody who's really just kind of it's
almost more interesting sometimes to see
somebody who's trying to play something
that it is not a great technical guitar
right i mean i just use that as one
example but like i and so i
i thought maybe there's something kind
of interesting about seeing drawings
animated that look like they were done
by a
15 year old in his notebook do you still
have those notebooks sketchbooks
yeah and the sketchbooks what would you
do you would draw little pictures and
then write notes next to them
yeah just mostly faces i'm not you know
i'm not good i can't draw like buildings
and trees and mountains but it's mostly
just
so how'd you do that with beaver some
butt head when you needed a background
when you needed a tree or you needed
i just forced myself to learn when i was
when i was animating the shorts actually
i remember the second one i did
i had cars and monster trucks in it and
i just could not
draw a car and i was finally just like
all right [ __ ] it and i got out the
sunday paper where they have the ads for
cars right and they have those like
illustrations i just traced one and i
started just tracing stuff
you know you get out the little triangle
and you draw like you know you can
i kind of figured out point perspective
and that's pretty quickly but
and then again you did the drawing you
did you
you wrote the script and then you went
ahead and voiced the [ __ ] things
yourselves and did
incredible voices would be some butthead
the voice thing is kind of to me was
what i was
that's the one thing that i've had the
natural thing to do i was i always did
imitations and stuff i had pretty i
could
were those original two voices based on
anyone
at that point that was the fourth short
i'd done that was the first time where i
had the drawing before i had the voice
all right and but beavis is sort of uh
there was a guy who
sat in the front of class and in algebra
who was actually like
i mean in calculus and he was like a
really smart guy he wasn't like beavis
he was
we had a teacher who was um a former
dallas cowboys cheerleader which it was
unheard of for there ever to be a hot
teacher
it was just like shot through the school
like oh my god like she she came in like
midway through the year and this guy
would just sit in
in the front row just like biting his
lip he was so excited and he would laugh
at everything
she said he just was like
[Laughter]
and mean sitting back imitating him
and he'd be writing really fast
and that stayed with you yeah and just
that kind of like that energy of just
but but i just kind of had drawn beavis
with a lighter and i just imagined him
kind of
based on sort of other people but i took
that laugh and that energy from that's
great